a thing to bear in mind sort of related
to what you were saying is disease which
we accept as part of life is actually
something fairly unusual in nature the
only places in nature where you see a
lot of disease happening is in insects
insects are highly subject to viruses
and there's a huge family of insect
viruses this is the basis of many
pesticide design strategies is to is to
spray crops with viruses that attack
insects the other area in the animal
world where you see a lot of disease is
human beings and the animals they have
domesticated so that cattle pigs poultry
and people are all fairly subject to
disease but for instance birds of prey
are not greatly subject to disease many
fewer diseases fish all all animal
groups have some susceptibility to
diseases but really human beings and
insects seem to be the most setup for
this and the reason that is advanced for
this is that these are the social
animals the insects and the human beings
and wherever you have intense social
activity not me I mean for instance in
some species a male and a female will
encounter each other only once in the
life of each individual then have sex
and that's it you know there is no
social life well so that's no no disease
can get a foothold there because
diseases require transmission and
contact diseases want to be able to move
from one person to another the reason I
mention this is because the rise of this
susceptibility to disease is something
that apparently
also was going on at the same time that
we were acquiring language beginning to
domesticate animals switching our diet
what we really are are the evolutionary
wreckage of a very chaotic can crazy
series of the pattern shifts that went
on between fifty and a hundred thousand
years ago now we are the inheritors of
that very interesting as long as I'm on
this subject very interesting
relationship between disease and
spirituality because pilgrimage sites
are the great disease vectors of the
ancient world I mean you can imagine
here you have a temple everybody comes
there to get cured and everybody comes
there and go and leave sick and because
then all these infected people have been
there there's a wonderful book I can't
remember the author but the title is
plagues and people's and it's a study of
Epidemiology and the history of disease
and its impact on human populations and
very interesting and has a lot to say I
think about psychedelic use as well by
implication because psychedelic use also
brings people together under very close
and intimate circumstances many times
well in a sense I mean I see AIDS as the
inevitable consequence of the ocean
crossing airliner you know always sites
of pilgrimage were sites of disease
conveyance and any virus worth that salt
would jump into this situation and
exploit it now as to the darker side of
the AIDS thing in terms of you know was
this a product of human engineering or
human intent or so forth and so on
that's an interesting question but in a
way it really doesn't matter it's an
it's a product of human behavior and I
don't mean necessarily sexual or
homosexual behavior I mean such
behaviors as travel pilgrimage the wish
to mix it all up
I mean think of the gene streaming that
is taking place in the 20th century I
mean I mean I know a Tibetan married to
an Egyptian woman and stuff like that's
going on all over the map so there's all
kinds of of crises when we were a
nomadic community the transmission of
disease was [ __ ] by the fact that
human groups didn't really come into
that much contact with each other and
when you're in a place like Terminal one
that Heathrow and you just look around
you
I mean my god you know I mean Muslim
priests Tibetan Lamas but Swan and
dignitary I mean and people too just
swarming and swarming and swarming and
using the bathrooms and coughing and and
in these airliners when they fly over
the ocean when they fly above 30,000
feet they recycle the air in such a way
that if there's one person who has a
problem 275 people are having their
immune systems on red alert by the time
you get to Tokyo or in New York not to
rave but
we are monkeys and monkeys love a hell
of a good fight and we have a hell of a
fight
bearing down on us because we have to
clean up the mess we are going to eat
we're not going to go silently into the
gentle night of extinction there it it's
just not going to happen that way
creativity is going to be unleashed
struggle is going to be an unavoidable
part of trying to steer this battleship
away from the cataracts of history in
which we are now caught
[Music]